i've heard different versions of events
whether it was guy richie's idea or
there was your idea
for sherlock holmes to drag up yeah was
that yours i'm afraid it was
it was your idea and were you surprised
at how you looked
i mean you are a beautiful man there's
no denying that uh i
it's true i would i would
[Applause]
i would uh i would i would probably kick
myself
out of bed i look like if my sister was
on a round of steroids
but i was i was trying to think if i was
mary if i was
if i was watson's cow what would be the
most
unsavory disguise to see sherlock show
up at
their wedding nuptials wearing well
that picture of you there's that picture
of you thank you now i don't want to
cause a rift
between the lovely friends but we do
have a picture of
jude as a woman we were this this is a
film we did well not together but
you were in as well look at jude look at
jude
[Applause]
now
that's a good look maybe i should shave
you went
i'm not sure how great i feel about that
actually
you look good i think men dressing as
women
is just bizarre
[Applause]
what about being told monkey fish before
all the being drunk
when they get inside your head you know
would they see everything from
from your point of view so what we did
was we've got
a little camera so that we could see
what it's like
being john malkovich on this very stage
now this is it's sort of you know a bit
2008.
and a bit 1945.
so if you slip that on your ear like
that
do you mind if i just
whole side of the show what it's like
arriving okay so you'll be met
back there there's russell he's an
assistant producer so you go back there
and
meet him and just keep your thoughts
going as you go that kind of internal
monologue
okay okay so we can watch that online
there hi russell
[Applause]
sorry i don't don't do collections
it's just one thing really quick i
really have to peep
[Music]
but what's the name of the tv show
[Applause]
[Music]
just leave it in the makeup
[Applause]
thank you what's it like being drunk
ladies and gentlemen please welcome john
malcolm
the thing is early in the week we had an
email from a viewer called
alice hanson who told us her best friend
emily farley she's going speed dating
tonight
i've never been to a speed dating event
so anyway it's at a pub in south london
so we thought we'd go in
and we'd have a peak okay so we can go
over there now i believe
okay this apparently although it's
called speed dating
it takes quite a long time so let's zoom
in
let's let's zoom in okay to emily
to the magic of television right now
talk to her
hello emily
[Applause]
hi emily listen your friend alice it's
graham norton here by the way
i'm not trying to pick you up
alice hanson she's a friend of yours
isn't she yeah all right she told me
you're going to be here
so we just gone to to sit in on your
speeding can you shove out of the way
and i'm going to sit in and i'm just i'm
going to just whiz through some of these
guys so we'll find something
okay okay
justin where are you from i'm from
hackney
hello hi james hello graham how you
doing
all right what are you doing for a
living i'm a veterinary technician
oh that's quite good yeah yeah how long
have you been single
i've been single probably about six
months
[Applause]
hi andy where do you live healing
[Music]
lovely what would you ask him kim if you
were there
does he like older women
andy do you like older women
[Music]
all right but let's not go there
i'm bearing you in mind but for the
moment
i'm ready for time i'm only giving
myself a minute for this
oh but your name's rupers
[Applause]
can we get andy back yes oh
hello emily emily emily emily let's see
you
do you like andy yes i do yes
okay give him a kiss give him a kiss go
on go on delighters
[Applause]
that's
[Music]
is
i need a drink after all
that's another thing we loved you as the
genie in aladdin oh that was fun
so we thought we might have our very own
genie on the show tonight
so is there anyone in the audience who
fancies a go at being a genie
oh look at them they do okay try and try
you uh what what what's your name
ewan sorry what you june
his name is joran
[Applause]
nice to have you here thank you no no
worries can i hear you later
here you stop frightening i know
don't piss off ewing okay so think of a
magic word
right something you know it's just you
magic word and that camera three
is going to do a kind of zoom crash on
you so so when i say go
you and you just do your magic word okay
so you and
go hi graham
wow how grandma i feel like we're in the
middle of a telethon right now
you and his learned to say hi graham
thanks to your dollars
please help you'll learn another phrase
by the end of the show
should we should we try another boy
oh actually you're wearing blue already
let's try you yeah okay
so into that camera your magic world
what's your name nick
g nick okay a friend of you
okay number three and go alakazam
wow
it was wow too good it was a bit like
you're you're very good at that
yeah alakazam time to dance
now i'm gonna dance with you and and
on
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
you go all right see you shortly
apparently apparently our genie
assistant is nick he is ready
so look at this look at this we've got
an actual uh
lamp now honestly panto season i don't
know how we managed to hire this
presumably there were children sobbing
in southampton
going where is the land took my life
okay so we rub it like that's disgusting
[Music]
[Applause]
gotta go to the there you go
there you go okay okay well done genie
now uh do your special work because
you've disappeared to do your special
magic thing again alakazam
very good well done
[Applause]
i don't know what he's doing here but it
works for me
very few genies tread water
i'm floating treading water with my arms
underneath me
oh
he's taking notes okay genie
genie be gone wow
i surprised myself so i'm just gonna get
my genie to help me
okay hang on oh yes because i forgot all
about cool creatures
[Applause]
good nick good oh there he is
[Music]
okay nick ready i need i need a lovely
funky dj
console please alakazam
look at that ladies and gentlemen
good work good work nick okay i tell you
what nick
you you can come back into the studio
come back to the shooter you can help us
in this thing okay there you go well
done
that was so great yeah right i'm not
floating anymore thank you okay
right here we go here we go it's the
robin and graham road show
hello sir gloves okay you're over there
now well done
so there's a mic there now nick i've got
some music
[__] put a shout out right now nick b
now for the blue people [__] going to
keep it real get ready for an alakazam
now many tingles though so it's the
robin graham road show
can you do a jingle a live jingle bell
welcome to the
robin graham radio show
very good that's back from a big shout
out from nick
okay and let's let's start the show
somewhere good evening robin
good evening graham welcome back once
again we got some shout outs
i got one going out right now to steven
buck he wants to shout out to jess
who's a best friend and he says stop
texting him
he's not interested yay you're
listening to the robin and graham
roadshow how cause i
am no you tit the jingle
welcome to the robin and graham radio
show
where is it where's michelle smith
where's michelle smith michelle smith
what's a shout out to esther best friend
that bloke you pulled
don't worry about trying to remember his
name you can do so much better
yo whoa
where's marlin marlon oh there he is
says marlon
ready we're gonna say we'd like to shout
out to his friend gregoire
don't worry girls love that you have got
a third nipple
oh three nipples abc way to go
[Applause]
you don't have to
secondly i will get my third nipple out
on the condition that robin williams
comes and touches it
here we go
this better be a real nipple
all right ready here we go ready ready
let's see
oh please please let it be a nipple
i have a third ball too
ready ready here we go okay ow oh
did i touch it i did oh brother
wow beautiful wow
well chicks really did that
i like that i like the fact that some
girl is going you've got another one
play with my third nipple girl you've
never had fun till you go third
once you've touched the third nipple
things get crazy
i get two nipples going but when the
third goes
the third nipple goes and then my fourth
penis jumps out
ladies and gentlemen please thank my
guest tonight the fantastic
mr robin
[Applause]
thank williams
[Music]
you